THE GAME IS ON.
THE FIRST THEREFORE HE GETS TO
THE PUCK FIRST.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE
CLASSIC TR
DEREK FORBORT SCORES.
2-0, BOST A THIRD
DEFENSEMAN UP BY THE
BLUE LINE.
IT THINS THINGS  AS
CARLO
KARLSSON WE JUST
SHOWED YOU OFF TO A
PRETTY
THE OTHER WAY.
PASTRNAK BURIES HOW MAN
TIMES HAVE WE SEEN
SUCCESS FOR THAT
CROSSBAR AND THEN
THIS LINE'S ABILITY?
0:32 SECONDS AFTER THIS
ON 2. YOU DON'T HAVE
TO DEFEND IT LIKE ITGO
THE WEST COAST.
THEY HAVE RST NHL POINT
STRIKES
1/2 YEARS BUT PAST
JACK LABLANC . SAIRD
LINE RIGHT WING.
IT AWAY.
FORWARD, THE TIP BY
HALL, THAT IS
GETTING SHOTS THROUGH.
IT IS A
BERGERON, McAVOY,
HE HAD A
REILLY , DEFLECTED.
VLASIC
DOWN AND FINDS
PASTRNAK RIGHT OUT
FRONT . A QUICK
LIHERTL
. A CL, CHANGES THAT
PUCK4:52 TO GO.
A TON OF TIME
NOW HOW HIGH IS THAT
REDIRECT? .
SAN JOSE CONTROLS,
THE NET EMPTY. THIRD
GOALS.
THEY HAVE BEEN POINT
SHOTS WITH REDIRECTS.
THEY BELIEVE THAT  IN T
GAME.
THE PUCK TAKES A
CRAZY BOUN
IT HITS THE BACK OF
THE NET